the head of public schools for the state
of nevada says children should be back
in the classroom
she addressed the state's kovid 19 task
force today
the i-team's vanessa murphy joins us
live to tell us
exactly what was discussed
brian the superintendent says children
deserve to be
back in the classroom she believes they
will get the best education
inside schools she says that can
actually help
prevent the spread of the virus here's
why
she says teachers and staff can make
sure precautions are being taken
children wearing masks social distancing
and washing their hands
she compared the washoe school district
to the clark county school district
she says washoe which has offered
in-person classes
and distance learning as well as a
combination of the two
has had a smaller percentage of children
ages 14
and under who have contracted covid19
that
increasingly shows is that the best way
to protect teachers
and students isn't to shut schools down
is to focus on all the measures that
will keep them
and their families friends and
neighborhoods safe
outside of the classroom
the clark county school district has no
plan to bring
children physically back to schools in
the near future
the head of the cdc the american academy
of pediatrics and dr
anthony fauci support children being
physically back in the classroom and
they point to data which shows that
schools and child care centers are not
major
sources for the spread of the virus now
the superintendent was one of several
people
who addressed the kovit 19 task force
today they discussed
a variety of issues the vaccine testing
and numbers the kovid 19 numbers in
nevada
really a concern right now reporting
live vanessa murphy
8 news now